benvenuti solite storie sullo scorso
video trova gli ingredienti slime
nascosti da annabelle ha raggiunto i 20
mila mi piace e vi avevo promesso i 20
mila mi piace il prossimo sarebbe stato
con lo slime air
se anche questo video raggiunge i 20
mila mi piace il prossimo personaggio
sarà il conte dracula il vampiro quindi
mi raccomando poliziotti iniziamo pure
la nostra ricerca qua in camera
magari lo slime ha dimenticato qualcosa
qua poi scrivete sempre nei commenti se
trovate qualcosa mi raccomando ok
andiamo un po cosa troviamo
no
[Musica]
umano
faccio un incubo
un piccolo
berlino
non lo sai per mi ha già preso una volta
mannaggia tra l'altro non so nemmeno
quante vite o penso che siano 5 come
ingressi quindi in realtà ho solo
quattro giorni adesso devo stare attenta
perché molto veloce più veloce di granny
quindi non so che strategia usare adesso
trovo qui ho perso due giorni in due
minuti tipo sono tre giorni adesso non è
possibile troppo forte penso che sia
molto difficile sconfiggere questo
personaggio cioè almeno io devo
solamente subito gli ingredienti slime
non devono per forza sconfiggerlo
ma penso che sarà molto difficile questa
science
non so esattamente cosa devo fare non so
qual sia il suo punto debole se almeno
sapessi qual è il suo punto debole
almeno potrei rallentarlo che c'è marino
berlino vuole dirci qualcosa che c'è
dimmi perché non riesce a parlare
mandare qualcuno ha dato un bacio in
fronte berlino dai bimbi merlino di btp
qual è il suo punto debole dirmi è però
sicuramente berlino ci aiuterà come
nelle altre challenge ora non so
continua a esplorare speriamo di non
trovarlo ma che berlino si è messo a
dormire
ma che cos'è questo biglietto scritto io
so come aiutarti ma devi fidarti di me
per prima cosa una tuta speciale dovrà
indossare
se gli ingredienti slime vorrei trovare
chi avrà scritto questo però è strano
tutto verde proprio come lo slime non è
che magari vuole imbrogliare me l'ha
scritto lui lo trovo questa tuta
speciale ma questo indizio non mi è
stato utile per ora papa
proseguiamo stavamo già criticato come
te non ho mangiato il carbonato non si
può assolutamente mangiare
uno show paese ha lasciato un fazzoletto
passa perché forse doveva pulirsi la
bocca
niente non ci saremmo mai riusciti in
questo lo abbiamo fatto
così questa certo quesito questa tuta
speciale con zaino protonico e fucile
protonico ti aiuteranno nella tua
missione cordate questa è la tuta di cui
parlava allora la prova subito
chissà se mi aiuterà parlamente proviamo
ok
proviamo a mettere questa tuta e
speriamo che davvero mi aiuti controllo
slime pronti 32 una bellissima tutta la
loro portata
bisazza e spero che mi aiuti davvero a
sconfiggere uno slider è fantastica ma
per fucile c'era scritto nel biglietto
che ci sarebbe stato anche fucile
merluzzo io non sono niente
controlliamo meglio il cile protonico
quasi un ep carbonato piccole questo
questo e come quello che mi ha aiutato a
sconfiggere grading vi ricordate bene
ora sono prontissimo ad affrontare lo
slime e speriamo di trovarlo da qualche
parte
sono sicura che è scappato adesso
andiamo a prenderlo
ok ragazzi come se quei fucili o il
bicarbonato
torniamo in studio per cacciare il
bicarbonato siamo il primo quindi stiamo
andando abbastanza bene anche se abbiamo
solo tre giorni ora con il fucile
andiamo alla ricerca dello slider forse
se vede che ho la divisa da ghostbusters
sarà lui a scappare
magari sarebbe l'ideale realtà dobbiamo
trovare gli altri ingredienti
andiamo alla culla
come funziona ok proviamo a fare e posso
prendere la colla del cavallo
no mi ha preso nuovamente nonostante
l'avessi colpito con il fucile
quindi ho capito che questo fucile
protonico qualcosa del genere lo
immobilizza per pochi secondi quindi
sono riuscito a prendere la colla almeno
spero eccola per fortuna però lui poi
come ho preso la colla
non so perché si è arrabbiato ancora di
più ed è comunque riuscito a prendermi
ho solamente due giorni non ce la farò
mai perché mi mancano lasciata dalla
spatola nella soluzione per lenti sono i
due giorni però almeno ho capito che
posso immobilizzarlo ancora non so qual
è esattamente il suo punto debole
l'unica cosa che so è che stava
mangiando cose a caso quindi potrebbe
essere che ha molta fame ecco qua i
nostri due ingredienti mi è venuta in
mente una cosa se lui stava mangiando
magari o e goloso ho molta fame quindi
ho preso un pacchetto di crackers non
penso che funzionerà ma posso comunque
provare a darglieli cercando di non
essere state cercando di non essere
presa
altrimenti avrò solo un giorno è
sicuramente non vincere
continuiamo a cercare gli ingredienti e
se lo vedo proverò prima dal pacco di
crackers non funziona dovrò rallentarlo
con il fucile protonico pronti anche a
ma si sa il fatto di meno
racconti
barbaro che non voglio porti in questa
foto guarda guarda o un poco di crackers
tieni
finanziamenti tutti però vedi che io non
voglio farti niente perché ti ho dato da
mangiare tutto presentarmi in cambio
quel pacco di crackers a trovare una
ciotola e la spatola mi aiuta il fucile
come fosse non ho più cibo mi dispiace
ragazzi allora scoperto il suo punto
debole vuole sempre mangiare mi mancano
solo due cose la struttura per lenti e
la paletta il problema è che non ho
nient'altro da mangiare telo scendere
giù in cucina e prendere qualcosa da
mangiare così forse riuscirà ad aiutarlo
beh
mi spiace ma che diventa con cristino
perché non penso che sia stato
aggressivo perché mogli o fiutato niente
da mangiare come faccio adesso devo
scendere giù in cucina piano piano
ok
[Musica]
ho paura che sia arrabbiato molto perché
ho usato il fucile protonico ma era
l'unico modo altrimenti mi avrebbe preso
comunque adesso con banco di patatine
per riuscire a passarli spero anche se
mi sembra che abbia molta fame vediamo
sentita gli altri due ingredienti in
cambio di questo
eccolo
ma che sto facendo
[Musica]
nascondiamoci
ecco aspetta aspetta aspettava un
qualcosa per te aspetta prima mi
prometti che mi dai
aspettami dividere per la soluzione per
lenti e la sporta la prima
secondo comunque io mi sono rinchiuso
qua dentro o no sto mangiando anche la
busta ma allora è proprio strano
avrei dovuto prendere tutto il cassetto
non solo un pacco di patatine e lo sa
che faccio non mi ha neanche dato un
ingrediente forse non erano abbastanza
per lui la mette fra farcela da sola
allora ragazzi ora ho bisogno del vostro
aiuto seriamente aiutarmi a trovare gli
altri ingredienti
altrimenti non so come farà più mi
sembra che lo sly mano
sono felice perché di un tasso di
paul è semplicemente mangiare ragazzi
comunque mi ha dato la palestra quindi
non ci resta che trovare la soluzione
per legge ma sbaglio o è andato in
studio o no che succede se si mangia gli
altri ingredienti
meglio andare subito quello che faccio
qualcosa di strano
sopprimendo la salute è verbo ok ora che
lo immobilizzato carni ok abbiamo tutti
ragazzi speriamo sia fuori tutto prima
che si sbagli
ok ragazzi possa far michelin fa ma
durerà poco il blocco quelli pro fare un
po di un po di razzi così forzatura di
più ok
speriamo che duri di più sbrighiamoci
darsi ovviamente lo slime uscirà perle
come lo slime non avevo dubbi
sembra che il blocco stia durando un bel
po quindi speriamo ci perde ritiro
slimer è proprio uno slam gigante ma che
chi potesse lei ma secondo voi a me
sembra tipo una trama di quelli
importanti siti tipo un cpi slime un
messo poca cosa così facciamo prima
mica
ci siamo quasi
[Musica]
ecco fatto l'edizione ci mette sempre un
sacco di tempo l'ultimo articolo fa col
sistema è pronto però lo slime è pronto
lo aspettano giorni niente perché non
funziona perché non funzionano sta
scomparendo sono fuggito
trecento abbiamo fatto questo gesto
qualcosa di strano
e come se il fucile protoni col abbia
assorbito e non so se ora sta dentro il
mio zainetto ho paura a controllare
secondo voi devo aprire lo zaino
vederseli dentro ma potrebbe ricomparire
quindi forse è meglio non farlo un mi
piace se volete una seconda parte con lo
slimer se in questo video raggiunge i 20
mila bbc si starà a dracula mosse
raggiunge il 30 mila mi piace ci sarà
una seconda parte con lo slime è stata
super divertente e ora vi lasciamo qua 4
casoli nistico e cliccare per vedere i
nostri altri viti e cate su quella che
preferite una visione dalle news live
slimer verde ciao